hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
phospholipids especially the membrane
phospholipids
so we know that plasma membrane of all
the biological cells
are composed of majorly phospholipids
and these phospholipids look somehow
like this
which have a hydrophilic head
and a hydrophobic tail the hydrophilic
head
is made up of glycerol and phosphate
residue with a charged group and that is
why it is hydrophilic and polar
whereas the tail is made up of
saturated or unsaturated fatty acids
so this is the overall structure of a
phospholipid in the plasma membrane
now let me tell you in the phospholipid
the r
part designated here could be different
it could be serine choline ethanolamine
and various different groups and
let me tell you that these phospholipids
can be obtained
via diet now other than that
many of these membrane phospholipids can
be synthesized
in the body as well so we would learn
about both
but first we should understand that
the distribution of these plasma
phospholipids
are heterogeneous for example if we
uh take a sphingomyelin or
phosphatidylcholine
they are generally present in the
exoplasmic
site that means the side which is facing
towards the
side towards the outer part of the cell
whereas phosphatidylserine or
ethanolamine
are generally found in the cytosolic
site
so they have different type of
distribution
in the membrane now forget about one
particular cell if we talk about
different cell types we would have
different proportions of phospholipids
present in their membrane
just to give you an example you have a
neuron
and you have a epithelial cell if we
look at their membrane
we would understand the proportion of
phospholipids that are present
they might have same types of
phospholipids they might have
phosphatidylcholine serine ethanolamine
etc
but the relative proportion of all these
phospholipids
could be very different now let's
dive deep into one particular cell let's
say an epithelial cell
now in this epithelial cell there is
phospholipid membrane
on the outer side there would be
membrane of endoplasmic reticulum
mitochondria lysosome or let's say
you have a peroxisome now if you
really analyze all of these membranes
carefully
one would notice that the degree of
these phospho presence of these
phospholipids that means the proportion
of phosphatidylcholine ethanol a minor
setting
is very different in different type of
membrane
and the relative proportion is also
different so
what we understood that these
phospholipids are distributed in a
heterogeneous fashion and their
distribution depends upon
cell type and even inside the cell
in different organelles they would have
a different proportion
now we can broadly classify
these phospholipids as
phosphoglycerides when the alcohol part
of these
are glycerol so you can see in
phosphatidyl ethanolamine
serine or in choline all the cases
the for the alcohol part is glycerol
and the difference lies in the our group
for example if you notice in
phosphatidylcholine versus serine the r
group is different now not only
phosphoglycerites there could be other
type
of phospholipids which could be present
which are known as
phosphosphingolipids in this
phosphofingo lipids the alcohol part
would be sphingosine
which is a long chain alcohol instead of
glycerol the
alcohol part is sphingosine
now the other parts
could be the same so you might have a
phosphate group
a choline attachment and
you would have a fatty acid tail but
here the difference lies
in the alcohol part and this particular
species is known as
sphingomyelin so sphingomyelin is
considered as
a phosphosphingolipid
so it's not a phosphoglyceride but it's
a phosphosphingolipid and it is
rich in axons and specially found in
central nervous system
now we already summarized that the
alcohol part of the lipid could be
different
glycerol or sphingosine
so this sphingosine containing
phospholipids are known as
at the simplest level they are known as
ceramides
and in the ceramides you would have
fatty acid parts fingosine and the r
group now if this r group
is just hydrogen then it is known as
ceramide
now if this r group is
a glucose then it is known as
glycosphingolipids so this is also
sphingolipids but it has a
sugar molecule attached to it so this is
a
subdivision of glycolipids so though we
were talking about phospholipids in
membrane
these glycolipids are also present even
inside the phospholipid just to
summarize we have phosphoglycerides
having glycerol as the alcohol part
and we have sphingolipids which have
sphingosine at the as the alcohol part
now the glycolipids generally contains
fingo seen as the alcohol part and they
have
glucose residues and this
glucocerebrosides which is one of the
most abundant glycolipid they are
generally
found in central nervous system in
myelinated neurons
and in some glias so let us now
look at the biosynthesis part of the
phospholipid
so inside any cell the phospholipid
biosynthesis takes place in the smooth
endoplasmic reticulum and the key enzyme
that helps in this process
is known as acyl transferases and there
are two
transferences which is known as gpat and
l-path
now first of all the synthesis starts
from glycerol 3 phosphate
which can be obtained from glycolysis or
glycolysis intermediates
and then it combines with fatty acyl coa
with the help of acid transference
enzymes sitting in the smooth
endoplasmic reticulum membrane
and the first step is formation of
phosphatidic acid
you can see the phosphate acid has a
rough structure of the backbone that we
are talking about
then a phosphatase enzyme would cleave
the phosphorylatic acid phosphate group
and it would form diacyl glycerol
which is another intermediate
now from the diazyle glycerol there
could be several transverse enzyme in
this particular case
choline phospho transfer is enzyme which
would
add phosphatidylcholine group and
ultimately
this would be forming the phospholipid
known as lecithin
so we took an example that how
biosynthesis of phospholipid takes place
in the smooth endoplasmic reticulum and
the rate limiting
enzyme here is the acyl transferase
now let me tell you lipid composition or
phospholipid composition governs
specialized membrane domains known as
lipid rafts
lipid drafts are enriched in
sphingolipins
and cholesterols and let me tell you
that
these lipid grafts are hub for signaling
molecules
for example it would have different
signaling molecules
such as receptors ion channels kinases
associated in this domain so lipid graft
which is dependent upon specific
composition of phospholipids
is very important for a cellular
function
now let me tell you that these
phospholipids
they not only form the membrane and form
a protective bilayer
but they also are important for
signal transduction one example comes
from g protein coupled receptor
signaling
where upon ligon ligand binding
the g alpha q subunit would activate an
enzyme known as phospholipase c
phospholipid c would cleave pip2 with
which is a phospho ionoside
which is a membrane phospholipid and it
would be cleaved into ip3
this ip3 would bind to ip3 receptor
and it would lead to calcium elevation
and further downstream signaling would
happen
but in this example we learned that
these membrane phospholipids could also
have
a signaling function and that is very
important
then we can also understand that
membrane phospholipid composition can
tell us about the cell's health for
example if we see a normal cell versus
apoptotic cell
we see that phosphatidylserine is
generally present in the
inner leaflet and it is seldom present
on the outer leaflet
but in case of apoptotic cells
phosphatidylserine
are generally found on the outer side
and their orientation is now flipped
from the inner side they are majorly now
found in the outer side and this is a
hallmark of
apoptosis so that is why membrane
phospholipid composition or their
distribution can tell us about the
cellular physiology
let me tell you about the fertilization
process
when one sperm entered the ova it
changed the membrane permeability
and nowadays scientists figure out that
the membrane
phospholipid composition also changes
as a result the membrane becomes more
impermeable to a second sperm
and that is how polyspermy is prevented
and this is really astonishing that how
membrane property
can really govern the cellular
physiology
now let me tell you about membrane
fluidity so membrane fluidity is
governed by the phospholipid composition
as well
so given which type of phospholipid is
present in the membrane it would
determine the
fluidity and also apart from
phospholipid
composition whether there would be
saturated or unsaturated phospholipid
that also governs the membrane fluidity
so in short we can understand so far
that phospholipid
composition governs so many factor in
terms of plasma membrane
now the biggest unanswered question that
are really important to know
is whether these membrane composition
change in major
physiological stage like when we are
fasting versus we are in a fade state
whether our cell has same membrane
composition or different
these kind of questions are still our
open question in the field
now also we need to understand our cell
is undergoing different type of stress
like stress by reactive oxygen species
thermal stress etc in those cases
whether the membrane composition changes
or whether the membrane composition
stays same
is another open question to the
scientific community
so in summary what we have learned in
this video
is what are phospholipids we classified
phospholipids we
looked at their structure and we also
focused on the distribution of the
phospholipids and what distribution of
phospholipids can tell us about
cellular physiology lastly we
looked at or explored several unanswered
question
that how phospholipid can govern
cellular properties
so i hope you enjoyed this video if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and
if you want to join my course in an
academy which is india's biggest
learning platform
you can use my code ap 10 to get a 10
discount
and do let me know in the comment how
you like my videos stay tuned for the
next video thank you